- What's up, guys, it's
Shawn Mendes and I'm gonna
be reading some of these thirst tweets.
♪ Yeah, show me your love ♪
You are weird and obsessed with pain,
but I love you for it.
Oh my God.
This is insane.
You know what the bad
thing about this tweet is,
is that I've seen this so many times.
Don't ask anybody to choke you.
Poetic, you should
write a song about that.
Well, thank you, that's sweet.
(Shawn chuckling)
I don't view my abs as art.
Haunted, you guys are haunted.
Don't put these things on the internet.
I think I could probably get arrested
for tweeting this stuff.
You guys dug for the
worst ones, didn't you?
Not reading that.
(Shawn laughing)
I'm sorry, there's a
line and she crossed it.
Nope, not reading that either.
Guys, that was me reading thirst tweets.
Yeah, a couple of you, I'm
sorry I didn't read your tweets,
but you need to stop
tweeting things like that.
(upbeat instrumental music)